strong words from Vice President Biden
who heads the White House task force on
guns my next guest has strong words for
me says I'm off the rails on guns in
America Ben Shapiro good Baby Ben larger
breitbart.com and you're from bullies
have a less Culture of Fear and
intimidation silences Americans so why
am I off the rails Mr Shapiro uh you
know honestly peers you've kind of been
a bully on this issue because what you
do and I've seen it repeatedly on your
show I watch your show um and I've seen
it repeatedly what you tend to do is you
tend to demonize people who differ from
you politically by standing on the
graves of the children of Sandy Hook
saying they don't seem to care enough
about the dead kids if they cared more
about the dead kids they would agree
with you on policy I think we can have a
rational political conflict that's a big
thing in politics that they do there
would be a big natural event that just
you know conveniently happens you know
this happens a lot of time a big
National tragedy will it'll just happen
you know because you know the way they
say it happens and then they'll use that
for decades why you should use their
policy which are likely policies that
take away your rights right but it's all
because it just happens that way they
are horrible horrible things but yeah
and it's all true too you know none of
it's fabricated it's not that's a rumble
talk it's not fabricated not it's not
Sandy Hook not Sandy Hook so don't don't
go don't go call me crazy about Sandy
Hook that's not what I'm talking about
to call you crazy what you getting at no
I I'm talking about some other stuff
that's fabricated we'll talk about it
after the stream really okay I can't
wait sorry guys we're gonna have to do
that's gonna have to be a rumble chat
because we might fight we might actually
Rumble if you come up with some [ __ ] bro
don't bro me bro I'm not your bro all
right we'll go over it conversation
about balancing right that's what they
do though that's what they do cards of
all of these different policies but I
don't think that what we need to do is
demonize people on the other side is as
being unfeeling about the about what
happened yeah you accuse me of standing
on the grades of the children I've seen
you do it I'll tell you like I say how
dare you I mean you can keep saying that
but you've done it repeatedly what you
do and I've seen you do it on the
program is you keep saying to folks that
if they disagree with you politically
then somehow this is a violation of of
what happened in Sandy Hook and you have
yet I I really like to hear your policy
prescriptions for what we should do
about guns because you say that you
respect the Second Amendment and you
know I brought this here for you so that
you can read it it's the Constitution
and I I would really like for you to
explain to me what you would do about
guns that would have prevented what
happened in Sandy Hook if you want to do
what you did in the UK right which is
Ban virtually all guns that is at least
a fair argument and we can have a
discussion about whether that's
something that we ought to do I've made
it very clear what I want to do which is
exactly what Mark Kelly wants to do and
in fact rather than address let's talk
about that rather than address your
comments to me about uh standing on the
graves of children at Sandy Hook you can
address them to Mark Kelly because he
agrees with everything that I've been
saying because he feels the same way as
does his wife they're gun owners they
both respect the Second Amendment of the
Constitution they don't want to take
away anybody's right to defend
themselves with guns they want to take
away certain types of guns out they want
to take away assault weapons which are
capable with magazines that we saw at
Aurora and Sandy Hook of unleashing a
ridiculous amount well this is a
question I wanted to ask appears because
I've seen you I've seen you talk about
assault weapons a lot and I've seen Mark
Kelly talk about assault weapons the
vast majority of murders in this country
that are committed with guns are not
committed with the saw weapons they're
committed with handguns willing to ban
handguns in this country across no
that's not what I'm asking for why not
let me ask you don't you care about the
kids who are being killed in Chicago as
much as the kids in Sandy Hook yes I do
then why don't you care about about
banning the handguns in Chicago
let me ask you this what was the weapon
used at Aurora in the movie theater it
was in yeah it was it was an assault
rifle sure okay what was the weapon used
in the Oregon Shopping Mall yeah I
believe it's an assault rifle correct
what was the weapon used at Sandy Hook
it was an assault rifle what was the
weapon used at the incident around
Christmas my understanding is that there
is and I am by no means a gun expert but
a little bit I have learned about this
over the years is that there is no such
thing as an assault rifle specifically
can you just quickly Google so we can be
clear on this point you know what it is
too every time I talk to like super gun
guys they go so deep into this [ __ ] and
they're like it's all [ __ ] dumb you
know what I mean they know so much stuff
they're like that's what I'm saying
there's like you could you could put a
paper clip in there and then it becomes
like they know all this crazy you know
what I mean no but go just what is an
assault rifle
um there is they're they're technically
uh a rapid fire magazine fed automatic
rifle yeah but we you know what okay
quick quick can everyone see this screen
right now yeah okay so I want to talk
about definitions there's a there's a
video I want to react to which talks
about how language has been re defined
certain certain phrases and words have
been redefined in the last five to ten
years like gender and that kind of so
here what let's click on this what
classifies a gun as an assault rifle the
military firearm that is chambered for
ammunition of reduced size or propellant
charge and that has a capacity to switch
between semiotic semi-automatic and
fully automatic fire which there is no
civilian that can purchase a gun an
assault rifle that can switch between
semi-automatic and fully automatic
there's no fully automatic gun available
to just go into a store in purchase
they're all semi-automatic yeah they're
all semi which still means super rapid
fire just to be clear it's not like
we're talking about like you gotta like
uh you know reload like like one of
those shotguns and bought illegally that
was it that was a that was an assault
rifle so the last four mass shootings in
America were all this all right and the
vastness that is the reason Mr Shapiro
and you can smirk at me and you can
laugh at me and you can accuse me of
standing on the graves of dead children
thanks guys like me and Mark Kelly
want to have assault weapons like that
removed from civilian hats your passion
on the issue doesn't really just all
guns could practically be considered
assault weapons now for why you want to
ban assault weapons remove the preferred
weapon of choice these killing machines
well I would like in the hands of
deranged young man all I'm asking is for
you to be philosophically consistent if
what you're worried about is the removal
of killing machines from the hands of
deranged young people then maybe we
should talk about a blanket gun ban and
let's get to what the left really wants
here and the you know you say that
you're forced about left or right
because in Britain this never is about
left or right this issue why is it here
well you know we can talk about Britain
in a second I think the reason that it's
about left and right here is because
fundamentally the right believes that
the basis for the Second Amendment and
they believe in the Second Amendment the
basis for the Second Amendment is not
really about self-defense and it's not
about hunting it is about resistance to
government tyranny that's what the
founder said and that's what the right
beliefs in this country are you fearing
yourself isn't that crazy that when you
say that the leftist like I remember
saying this in school when I still went
to BLS which is like a liberal School
Boston Latin School and they'd be like
you that's what you're afraid of that's
why people should have guns because of
the government and it's like yeah
[ __ ] that is exactly why didn't
you just take a history class about
about Nazi Germany where they took away
all their guns took away all their guns
to cattle cars because they had no idea
I feared the possibility of a tyranny
rising in this country in the next 50 to
100 years let me tell you something
cares the fact that my grandparents and
great grandparents in Europe didn't fear
that is why they are now ashes in Europe
so this this kind of leftist revision is
history where there's never any fear of
democracy going usurpatious or
tyrannical is just a decision just to
clarify your position then the answer to
Sandy Hook as it was to Aurora as it was
to Gabrielle giffus as it was to
Columbine Virginia Tech is you do
nothing is that your position that's not
my position I actually position my
position is that we have to calibrate
laws that are designed to get hands uh
guns out of the hands of bad people and
keep guns in the hands of good people
who want to buy them
how do you do that well I think one of
the ways that you do that is by better
screening for mental illness I think
that you do better background checks was
Adam Lanza's mother a good person I
don't know whether she was a good person
or a bad person yeah responsible with
her guns has there been any evidence to
suggest she was not a good person no but
there's been a significant evidence
wait a minute are your criteria of the
good people should be allowed the guns
and the bad people shouldn't she would
have been allowed the guns she was an
irresponsible person she didn't keep her
guns locked up and that and that should
be against us
because it's not what we said that's
what he said but then he's just
expanding it okay explain he said he
said good to have more guns in the hands
of good people unless in the hands are
bad and then he took that as in the way
as like like he meant responsible with
your guns in that statement he also
meant responsible with your guns not
just being morally good
moving forward because right before that
peers asked him what would you do
differently and he said good people not
bad people he wasn't talking about the
past
so you know no Pierce is playing you
know the craziest thing too is that
there's literally more more people that
die every single weekend in Chicago from
shooting than unarmed black people die
from cops in like an entire year isn't
that crazy and that's what we literally
burned down cities for well yeah there's
that but we have bigger issues because
apparently it's just a crazy doctor
because all the politicians dropped it
no one's protesting and protesting in
the streets anymore I don't truly most
of the BLM signs that used to be in
front windows are gone nobody cares
anymore do these people anymore do these
people even see that they got that they
got fooled they got Tom fooled some good
old Tom Foolery occurred
I don't know why you disagreeing she
becomes a bad person does she well no
it's not a matter of it's not a matter
of morally criteria good and bad so is
she good or bad you're right Paris I
should have said responsible versus
irresponsible that's correct okay so she
goes from good to bad now she goes from
responsible to irresponsible let's take
a break let's come back and talk more
about this because we don't agree that
was nine years ago look at baby Ben
Shapiro that was when he was with
Breitbart there was something that
happened at Breitbart that he became
really turned off by and he quit
unceremoniously just walked out and
that's when he started the job the daily
wire so I've actually heard him talk
about this whole assault rifle
conversation and the language around it
since then so he's also educated and
learned since then which it doesn't
surprise
[Music]